always been in recovery a long time
that's how people react and but
no one look I the fact of the matter is
I made it clear that if I made me one
feel comfortable I feel badly about
understand me I'm not sorry for any of
my intentions I'm not sorry for anything
that I have ever done I've never been
disrespectful intentionally to a man or
always said you're not changing your
brand you're not wearing any funny hats
is this whole episode of the past week
is this gonna change how you campaign
well I think it's gonna have to change
someone how I campaign it's just like
you know the new thing is selfies
everybody wonders why if I take the
selfie so they don't put it on Instagram
so so it's not put up me if I had the
camera at least I make sure it's a photo
and I'm not doing something else because
you have to wonder you know what what I
think is being useful and so it's all
changed come on you're each of you are
aware of it in your personal
relationships the changes and it's not a
bad thing it's a new thing it's
important and I'm sure it's going to
take a while for it to settle out but
it's about for me I'm told by the
lawyers but I've got to be careful what
I say so that I don't start
clock ticking and changed my status but
it is I am very close to making the
decision to stand before you all
relatively soon that III think in weeks
Paes weeks what's the holdup putting
everything together man
putting everything together even if I
knew for certain that I was going to run
for president back in Thanksgiving it's
my intention of the beginning if I were
to run and be the last person to
announce I and so if everybody else
there day then I get a shot and then we
off to the races
the lack of a normal operation this
clear makes your response trickier no
I I would pick someone else ago that you
were the most progressive person in
Democratic Party there's a lot of
candidates in this race I say the
liberal I didn't say progressive well
here's the point that's changing to for
my whole career I wish I had been
labeled in Delaware the seven times I
ran as a moderate
I was never labeled as a moderate if you
look at my record the ACLU look at my
record with all of the traditional
liberal organizations I have never
walked away from I'm not I'm not sure
when everybody else came out and said
they're for gay marriage
I'm not sure when everyone else came out
and talked about a lot of things I've
talked about but my point is is the
definition a progressive now seems to be
changing that is are you a socialist
well but that's a real progressive or
you believe in you know whatever I mean
so I I was talking about up until this
last time around the traditional
judgments of whether or not you were
quote a liberal was whether or not what
were two positions on race war on women
what's your position on on LGBT
community
put your positions on civil liberties
you know I'll stack my record on those
things against anybody who's ever run
who is running now or who will run but
are you suggesting this party will find
out whether I can win in the primary
thank you but you know let me say one
last thing here's the deal I think you
guys if you look at all the polling data
and look at the actual results the party
has not
- the way whatever how you tried to want
to characterize it whatever calculation
you just made the fact of the matter is
the vast majority of the members of the
Democratic Party are still basically
liberal moderate Democrats in the
traditional sense and you look at those
I went into 65 66 67 races on the ground
I campaigned I think for virtually every
one of the 41 people who want
show me the really left left left left
wingers who beat a Republican a
Republican so the idea the democratic
party is sort of stood on this head I
don't get and by the way we should
welcome the party should welcome this I
know how you want to characterize it the
progressive left it should be welcomed
we should have a debate about these
things that's not a bad thing
but the idea all of a sudden the
democratic party woke up and and you
know everybody asks we know what kind of
Democrat I'm gonna follow Biden Democrat
[Music]